all right hello everybody my name's
Maude
get me do my sea mouth where's my baby
it was glowing Oh God where did it go
Oh No oh okay
awesome thank you the Geoffrey Billy
Samwise Marshall for protecting much
Seema
oh my god I thought it was gone forever
I was very worried okay so I've got one
target in mind and Honda and that is
amazing but I've got one target in mind
and that is shaving and then going to
that ship over there so I don't know
what to face I don't know what to expect
I mean it probably is the radiation
that's my primary concern question mark
where's your back
I mean exploring anything unknown in an
ocean and going forever and ever
I didn't encounter anything last time I
got kind of close so I can only imagine
that it'll be totally 100% okay and I'll
be super chill although a radiation
detective is that hurting me
oh god it's hurting me okay never mind
god damn it ahh Oh God whoops sorry okay
so okay change of plans what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna go try to find lead
that's happened everyone ignore what
just happened in front of us but I'm
gonna go find lead because there's a way
to make a lead line suit so I gotta look
up where lead is and then go get led so
I'll be right back
turn mm what's with all the light that's
so cool
ooh spooky scary spooky scary I'm gonna
get you what was that ah cool
modification ah what the hell why why
who did that
why who did that Hey goddamn it Greg I
don't know what that was man I shouldn't
be exploring these depths these
dangerous dangerous depths okay so what
I need to make Len is actually really
weird books in this game lead is created
by mixing copper and silver which is
totally not true but hey I'm not gonna
question I think I just got it I don't
know wait how much led to a need I might
as well get some more silver hmm not
good and oh god is so dark aw it's so
scary I don't know what Oh God give me
silver Oh give me if you'll give me fire
give me that which I desire burning Lily
learning that's not how the song goes
there we go silver okay that's enough
I'm swimming in the ocean in the ocean
free I'm swimming in the ocean look at
me I'm swimming in the ocean a scared
little baby oh god what am I just looked
in this window and there was just a
figure standing in my home base oh yes
thanks Karen for calling me by my
official name captain okay so oh yeah oh
it's balls oh I know how to make balls
that's my other specialty besides Lube
I know balls and lube and that's the
only things I know so what I need is the
oh I need to lid ah
and I need more copper if only I had no
think I go I just won okay so it's gonna
be like that huh all right then well
time to find more copper which means
that I have just got to find more little
deposits of everything phony I was able
to get a ridge shut up shut up he's
gonna be a headline for some day for me
Marga Blair yells at ocean everyone
confused sure
don't you hear a moaning in there ah the
big babies oh we live in the ocean there
we go
that should be enough okay I would like
more copper for a battery though will
music got intense
oh gosh should I be worried boomba
jovica BAM hello Miguel medium a BAM Oh
ocean is really fun bang Oh bear we love
it and love to eat all the fish and
we're probably gonna die what it's
really bad oh I already have that CMOS
now needed
oh god dammit another one who hypnotized
should stop probably singing this stupid
song doop doop doop doop v dipper every
day for their print and dumping
protector it's deeper deeper deeper
deeper sounds less intense when I
singing I don't know why I've usually
been told that I'm badass by a panel of
myself in the mirror there we go one
more copper goddamn about temped oh no
oh no
oh no I'm on my own I don't like being
on my own I'm very slow on my own
suddenly got a lot scarier when I was
outside of my little Zoom Zoom device
maybe I should be concerned maybe a
steam ovens yeah no thank you
oh you're fast Oh God he ate that fish
oh yeah what will he do to me oh no he
ate that fish and now he's gonna eat me
oh my god
and squab am Hospital II okay cool we
got everything we need
how about I am it came with the helmet -
okay so radiation suit and we are 100%
chill I'm gonna eat that I'm gonna drink
of that and I'm gonna drop pretty much
everything in my bags in here because I
do not know what I'm gonna be getting oh
I need another one
hang on oh sweet that is perfect
that's Jeffrey eventually I'm gonna have
a locker for all of my children but just
not now because I'm lazy and don't have
the materials anyway okay so now I got
pretty much everything that I need I'm
gonna cook up this fish and that'll be
the last thing that I need on the way
you can also cure food it'll it won't
rot as quickly but I don't think I'm
gonna be gone that long so with that
being said I should probably get healed
I'll be fine I'll be fine I'll probably
fine I'll probably be fine I say as I
save really heard so now that I go oh
left that right there okay so now we can
finally go on our expedition to the ship
after a little bit of sidetrack you were
all so excited wow we really got some
air on that one Hot Diggity
can we do that again hmm
it's fun okay but enough fun this is a
serious mission I don't know if this is
gonna provide like perfect protection
from the radiation but I imagine it
would because I mean hey it's lined with
lead
I mean number one I don't know how I'm
gonna be able to swim with this on bugs
oh so creepy I don't know it's still so
creepy seeing that in the distance like
that
yeah yeah do you guys hear that
oh it's stop driver oh god oh god sorry
everybody
that was scary to me well anyway I don't
know where to go to get in if I get in
at all so did that a thing excuse me one
second
I know like I'm I don't know what all of
this is so it's all very new to me is
that oh supply crate disinfected water
how nice
ooh nothing okay oh yes
Oh forsaken oh I need that oh it feels
so good okay
hot damn that's really handy I had no
idea so if I dig in the sand here is
there gonna be anything else
tides digging the sand to find out what
the rest heck rest of this is no idea oh
that's so cool okay
but anyway it's not part of my mission
so now
thank you Karen you know I like you a
lot more than I previously Don because I
don't know just something about our
relationship just seems to be working
for me now
as more containers in there I might as
well you never know what you're gonna
find even though I have this funny
feeling I'm probably gonna die
oh cool battery thank you oh he's cool
oh cool
yes there's nothing in here okay that's
not as good welcome aboard
thanks Karen babe babe Karen Karen babe
baby Karen sit some more of those guys
stumpy what did I call you slump us
flume Pete stupi I think stupid yes
Timmy fry it it okay yep yes welcome
aboard captain
thanks Karen oh whoa oh I found my way
in
oh whoa whoa bonkers whoa
oh whoa bunker wankers where am I okay
whoa oh oh oh so cool
ah seppuku Oh God that didn't sound good
oh god what was it I have no idea
well that's not good
uh I got something power efficiency
something or other
oh my god oh this is so weird oh wow oh
this is something that I totally didn't
expect out of this game
Oh Oh
blackbuck device not found oh well then
may this have been sabotage
it is 7% of habit all sections of ship
were rendered uninhabitable
uninhabitable
oh hey hi there how's it going are you
okay you're able I'll flake you up you
don't hurt that bad but I don't want
nothing oh god oh no oh no oh my oh good
what happened I don't like it I don't
know where it went
don't worry Oh
oh so cool
okay maybe this is another way in
goddamn there's a lot of little do
daddies Jack give a key scavengers UE
scanty lacquers is there anything I can
do over here
probably not boo PD okay so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna go back around and
I'm gonna get back to my ship because
that's one thing I do not want to lose
Oh exchange battery Q okay so if I were
just to assume there's probably like
dozens if not hundreds of little nooks
and crannies around this thing that I
could probably explore for a long long
whoa can't even go that way God well
what that Oh No
what the hell what oh no oh come on yeah
where am I the hell's happening okay
there we go goddamn so I can't even go
that way
that's so weird why wouldn't I be able
to go that way I have no idea
oh wow ah it's like invisible walls
around this bazaar why would there just
be invisible walls like that it's gonna
drown me eventually okay there we go
okay I'm free okay it was just some
weird Wow
I never want to go down there for as
long as I live oh my god that's
terrifying
oh that's terrifying oh so cool okay so
basically uh what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna end this episode here right back
into the safety of my seamoth hello
buddy
thanks Karen love you baby and then I'm
gonna pick this up in the next episode
I'm gonna continue to explore this uh
derelict
and hopefully I'll go somewhere good so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know how i'm doing the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video